NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
I'm going to talk
about I/O models.
Just to get a sense,
how many people
know a model called I/O model?
And how many people don't?
It doesn't matter.
I'm just curious.
As some of you may
know, I/O models
have a really rich history.
And they're pretty fascinating.
They are all central to this
problem of modeling the memory
hierarchy in a computer.
We have things like RAM
model of computation
where you can access anything at
the same price in your memory.
But the reality of
computers is you
have things that are
very close to you that
are very cheap to
access, and you
have things that are very
far from you that are big.
You can get 3 terabyte
disks these days,
but are very slow to access.
And one of the big
costs there is latency.
Because here, the head has to
move to the right position,
and then you can read
lots of data really fast.
The disk actually can
give you data very fast,
but the hard part is getting
started in reading stuff.
And so this is the sort
of thing we want to model.
These kinds of computers
have been around for decades,
as we'll see.
And people have been
trying to model them
in as clean a way as possible
that works well theoretically
and matches practice
in some ways.
I have just some fun
additions to this slide.
You can keep getting
bigger, go to the internet,
get to an exa- or a zettabyte.
You have to look up all
the words for these.
In the universe,
you've got about 10
to the 83 atoms, so maybe
roughly that many bits.
But I don't know if
there's a letter for them.
So how do we model this?
Well, there's a lot of models.
This is a partial list.
These are sort of the core
models that were around,
let's say, since
this millennium.
So we start in 1972 and
work our way forward.
And I'm going to go
through all of these
in different levels of detail.
There's a couple of
key features in a cache
that we want to model or
maybe a few key features.
And then there's some
measure of simplicity, which
is a little hard to define.
The goal is to get all four
of these things at once.
And we get that more
or less by the end.
So first section is on this
idealized two-level storage,
which was introduced
by Bob Floyd in 1972.
This is what the first page
of the paper looks like.
It's probably typeset
on a typewriter
it looks like and underline,
good old days of computer
science, very early days
of computer science.
And this was published
in a conference
called The Complexity of
Computer Computations.
How many people have
heard of that conference?
No one.
Wow.
There it is.
It's a kind of a
classic, because it
had Karp's original
paper on NP-completeness.
So you've definitely
read this paper.
But there are a lot of
neat papers in there
and a panel discussion including
what should we call algorithms,
which is kind of a fun read.
So this is in the day when
one of the state of the art
computers was the PDP-11.
This is what PDP-11,
or one of them,
looks like by probably
owned by Bell Labs.
But Dennis Ritchie
and Ken Thompson's
the inventors of C and
Unix, working away there.
It has disks, each of which is
about 2 megabytes in capacity.
And it has internal memory which
was core memory at the time.
So each of these is a little
circular magnetic core.
And it stores 1 bit.
And in total, there
are 8 kilobytes.
So you get a sense of
already this being an issue.
And this is why they
wrote their paper.
So here's the model
they introduced,
a very simple model, maybe
the simplest we'll see.
You have your CPU, which
can do local computation.
And then you have your
memory, which is very big.
But in particular, it's divided
into these blocks of size B.
So each block can
have up to B items.
And what you're allowed to
do in one block operation
is read two of the blocks.
You can read all the
items in the block.
So let's say you
read these two items.
You pick some subset of
those items to pick up.
And then what
you're allowed to do
is store them somewhere else.
So you can pick some other
target block like this one
and copy those elements
to overwrite that block.
I mean, there's no
computation in this model,
because he was just interested
in how you can permute items
in that world.
So simple model, but
you get the idea.
You can read two blocks, take
up to B items out of them,
stick them in here.
Here, we just ignore what
the order is within a block,
because we're assuming you
can just rearrange once you
read them in and spit them out.
So don't worry about the
order within the block.
It's more for every item,
which block is it in?
And we're assuming here
items are indivisible.
So here's the main
theorem of that paper.
If you're given N items and
you want to permute them into N
over B blocks, which means each
of those blocks is going to be
full-- let's say that's sort
of the most interesting case--
then you need to use N over
B log B block operations
even for a random permutation on
average with high probability.
So this is kind of nice
or kind of interesting,
because just to touch
those blocks requires
N over B block operations.
But there's an extra log
factor that starts to creep up,
which is maybe a little bit
surprising, less surprising
to people who are familiar with
I/O models, but at the time,
very new.
And I'm making a
particular assumption here,
but just a small thing.
I thought I'd go through
the proof of this theorem,
because it's fairly simple.
It's going to use a
slightly simplified
model where, instead of copying
items, you actually move items.
So these guys would
disappear after you put them
in this new block.
Because we're thinking
about permutation problems,
again, that doesn't
really change anything.
You can just, for
every item, see
what path it follows to
ultimately get to its target
location, throw away
all the extra copies
and just keep that
one set of copies.
And that will still be a
valid solution in this model.
So how does the lower bound go?
It's a simple
potential argument.
You look at for
every pair of blocks,
how many items
are there in block
i that are destined for block j?
You want to move from
block i to block j.
This is going to be
changing over time.
This is where they
currently are.
So that's nij.
You take and nij, log nij,
and sum that up over all
i's and j's.
That's the potential function.
And our goal is to
maximize that potential.
Because it's going to be--
for those familiar
with entropy--
negative entropy.
So it's going to be maximized
when all the items are
where they need to be.
This is when everything is
as clustered as possible.
You can only have a
cluster of size B,
because items can only be
up to B in the same place.
One way to see this, in
the target configuration,
nii is B for all i.
Everyone's where
they're supposed to be.
And so that potential gives
you the number of items
times log B. And this
is always, at most,
log B. And so that's the biggest
this could ever hope to get.
So our goal is to increase
entropy as much as possible.
And we're starting
with low entropy.
If you take a
random permutation,
you're trying to get the
expected number of guys
that are where they're
supposed to be.
It's very small,
because most of them
are going to be destined
for some other block.
So we're starting with
the potential of linear.
We need to get to N log
B. And then the claim is
that each block operation we
do can only increase potential
by, at most, B. And
so that gives us
this bound of the
potential we need
to get to minus the potential we
had divided by how much we can
decrease potential in each step,
which is basically N over B log
B minus a little O.
Why is this claim true?
I'll just sketch.
The idea is this fun fact,
the x plus y log x plus y
is, at most, x log x plus
y log y plus x plus y.
What this means is if
you have two clusters,
our goal is to sort
of cluster things
together and make bigger groups
that are in the same place
or in the correct place.
So if you have two clusters
x log x and y log y
contributing to this
thing and you merge them,
then you now have
this potential.
And the claim is that could
have only gone up by x plus y.
And when you're moving B
items, the total number
of things you're moving
is B. So you can only
increase things by B.
So it was a quick sketch
of this old paper.
It's a fun read, quite
clear, easy argument.
So we proved this theorem that
you need at least N over B
log B. But what is
the right answer?
There's actually not a
matching upper bound.
Of course, for B at constant,
this is the right answer.
It's N, but that's
not so exciting.
On the upper bound
side, this paper
has almost matching lower bound.
It's another log, but
not quite the same log,
N over B log N over
B instead of log B.
And the rough idea
of how to do that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, question.
ERIK DEMAINE: I said a
tall disk assumption.
I'm assuming N over
B is greater than B.
The number of
blocks in your disk
is at least the size of a block.
AUDIENCE: You needed
that in the proof?
ERIK DEMAINE: I needed
that in the proof I think.
Good question, Where
N over B log B.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
Exactly.
Yeah, that's where I'm using it.
Thanks.
Otherwise this expectation
doesn't work out.
I mean, if you have one block,
for example, this will fail,
because you need
zero operations.
So there has to be some trade
off at the very small regime.
OK.
So the way to get N
over B log N over B
is basically a radix sort.
In one pass through
the data, you
can rewrite everything to
have the lower order bits of 0
before all the lower
order bits of 1.
So in N over B, you can sort
by each bit in the target
block ID of every item.
And so you do log
of N over B things,
because that's how
many blocks there are.
And so this is how
many passes you
need by a binary radix sort.
You can achieve that bound.
And the paper actually claims
that there's a lower bound.
It's a little strange,
because there's
a careful proof given for this.
And then this claim just
says, "by information
theoretic consideration--"
this is also true.
This is in the
days when we didn't
distinguish between
big O and big omega
before [INAUDIBLE] paper.
But this is not true.
And we'll see that
it's not true.
It was settled about
14 years later.
So we'll see the right answer.
This is almost the right
answer, but it doesn't quite
work when B is very small.
And one way to see
that is when B is 1.
When B is 1, the right
answer is N, not N log N.
So when B is less
than log N over B,
then there's a slightly
different answer
which we'll get to later.
But that was the early days.
There's some other fun quotes
from this paper foreshadowing
different things.
One is the word RAM model,
which is very common today,
but not at the time.
And it says, obviously,
these results
apply for distant drums,
which was probably
what they were thinking
about originally,
but also when the
pages, the blocks,
are words of internal
memory and the records
are the bits in those words.
So this is a word RAM model.
Here, I said just ignore the
permutation within each block.
But you can actually
do all the things
you need to do for
these algorithms using
shifts and logical or,
xor, and operations.
So all these algorithms work
in the word RAM model, too,
which is kind of nifty.
Another thing is
foreshadowing, what
we call the I/O model, which
we'll get to in a little bit.
It says, "work is in progress."
He got scooped, unfortunately.
"Work is in progress--" unless
he meant by someone else--
"attempting to study
the case where you
can store more than two pages."
Basically, this CPU can
hold two of these blocks,
and then write one back out, but
has no bigger memory than that.
or bigger cache.
So that's where we
were at the time.
Next, chapter in
this story is 1981.
It's a good year.
It was when I was born.
And this is Hong
and Kung's paper.
You've probably heard about
the red-blue pebble game.
And it's also a two-level
model, but now there's
a cache in the middle.
And you can remember
stuff for a while.
I mean, you can
remember up to M things
before you have
to kick them out.
The difference here is
there's no blocks anymore.
It's just items.
So let me tell you a
little bit about the paper.
This was the state of the
art in computing at the time.
The personal computer
revolution was happening.
They had the Apple
II, TRS-80, VIC-20.
All of these originally had
about 4 kilobytes of RAM.
And the disks could store
maybe, I don't know,
360 kilobytes or so.
But you could also connect a
tape and other crazy things.
So, again, this was relevant.
And that's the setting
they were writing this.
They have this fun quote.
"When a large computation is
performed on a small device--"
at that point, small devices
were becoming common--
"you must decompose
those computations
to subcomputations."
This is going to require a lot
of I/O. It's going to be slow.
So how do we minimize I/O?
So their model-- before I get
to this red-blue pebble game
model, it's based on a vanilla
single color pebble game model
by a Hopcroft,
Paul, and Valiant.
This is the famous interrelation
between the time hierarchy
and space hierarchy paper.
And what they said is, OK,
let's think of the algorithm
we're executing as a DAG.
We start with some
things that are inputs.
And we want to compute stuff
that this computation depends
on having these two
values and so on.
In the end, we want to
compute some outputs.
So you can rewrite computation
in this kind of DAG form.
And we're going to model
the execution of that
by playing this pebble game.
And so a node can
have pebbles on it.
And for example, we could
put a pebble on this node.
In general, we are allowed
to put a pebble on a node
if all of its predecessors
have a pebble.
And pebble is going to
correspond to being in memory.
And we can also throw away
a node, because we can just
forget stuff.
Unlike real life, you can
just forget whatever you
don't want to know any more.
So you add a pebble.
Let's say, now we
can add this pebble,
because its predecessor
has a pebble on it.
We can add this pebble over
here, add this pebble here.
Now, we don't need this
information anymore,
because we've computed
all the things out of it.
So we can choose to
remove that pebble.
And now, we can add this one,
remove that one, add this one.
You can check that I got all
these right, add this one,
remove that one, remove,
add, remove, remove.
In the end, we want
pebbles on the outputs.
We start with pebbles
on the inputs.
And in this case, their goal was
to minimize the maximum number
of pebbles over time.
Here, there's up to four
pebbles at any one moment.
That means you need
memory of size four.
And they ended up proving
that any DAG can be executed
using N over log N
maximum pebbles, which
gave this theorem time.
If you use t units of
time, you can fit in t
over log t units of space,
which was a neat advance.
But that's beside the point.
This is where Hong and
Kung were coming from.
They had this pebble model.
And they wanted to use
two colors of pebbles, one
to represent the shallower
level of the memory hierarchy
in cache, and the other to say
that you're on disk somewhere.
So red pebble is
going to be in cache.
That's the hot stuff.
And the blue pebbles
are our disk.
That's the cold stuff.
And, basically, the same rules--
when you're initially
placing a pebble,
everything here has to be red.
You can place a red pebble
if your predecessors
have red pebbles.
We start out with the
inputs being blue,
so there are no red pebbles.
But for free-- or not for free.
For unit cost, we can
convert any red pebble
to a blue pebble or any
blue pebble to a red pebble.
So let's go through this.
I can make that one red.
And now, I can
make this one red.
Great.
Now, I don't need it right now.
So I'm going to make it blue,
meaning write it out to disk.
I make this one red,
make this one red.
Now, I can throw that one away.
I don't need it
on cache or disk.
I can put that one
on disk, because I
don't need it right now.
I can bring that one
back in from cache,
write this one out,
put that one onto disk,
put that onto a disk.
Now, we'll go over here,
read this back in from disk,
finish off this
section over here.
And now, I can throw that away,
add this guy, throw that away.
What do I need?
Now, I can write
this out to disk.
I'm done with the output.
Now, I've got to read
all these guys in,
and then I can do this one.
And so I needed a cache
size here of four.
The maximum number of red
things at any moment was four.
And I can get rid of those guys
and write that one to disk.
And my goal is to get
the outputs all blue.
But the objective
here is different.
Before, we were minimizing,
essentially, cache size.
Cache size now is given to us.
We say we have a
cache of size M.
But now, what we count are the
number of reads and writes,
the number of switching
colors of pebbles.
That is the number I/Os.
And so you can think of
this model as this picture
I drew before.
You have cache.
You can store up to M items.
You can take any blue item.
You could throw them
away, for example.
I could move a red item
over here, turn it blue.
That corresponds to
writing out to disk.
I can bring a blue item
back in to fill that spot.
That corresponds to reading from
disk as long as, at all times,
I have at most M red items.
And these are the same model.
So what Hong and
Kung did is look
at a bunch of different
algorithms, not problems,
but specific algorithms,
things that you
could compute in the DAG form.
The DAG form is,
I guess you could
say, a class of algorithms.
There's many ways
to execute this DAG.
You could follow any
topological sort of this DAG.
That's an algorithm
in some sense.
And so what he's finding is the
best execution of these meta
algorithms, if you will.
So that doesn't mean it's the
best way to do matrix vector
multiplication.
But it says if you're following
the standard algorithm,
the standard DAG that you get
from it or the standard FFT
DAG--
I guess FFT is
actually an algorithm--
then the minimum number
of memory transfers
is this number of red
or blue recolorings.
And so you get a variety.
Of course, the speed-ups,
relative to the regular RAM
analysis versus this analysis is
going to be somewhere between 1
and M, I guess for
most problems at least.
And for some problems, like
matrix vector multiplication,
you get very good M odd even
transpositions [INAUDIBLE]
you get M. Matrix
multiplication, not quite
as good red M and FFT.
Sorting was not analyzed
here, because sorting
is many different algorithms.
Just one specific algorithm
analyzed here, only log M.
So I don't want to go
through these analyzes,
because a lot of them will
follow from other results
that we'll get to.
So at this point,
we have two models.
We have the idealized
two-level storage of Floyd.
We have the red-blue pebble
game of Hong and Kung.
This one models
caching, that you
can store a bunch of things.
But it does not have blocks.
This one models blocking,
but it does not have a cache,
or it has a cache
of constant size.
So the idea is to
merge these two models.
And this is the Aggarwal
and Vitter paper many of you
have heard of, I'm sure.
It was in 1987, so six
years after Hong and Kung.
It has many names.
I/O model is the
original, I guess.
External Memory Model
is what I usually use
and a bunch of people here use.
Disk Access Model has the nice
advantage of you can call it
the DAM model.
And, again, our goal is to
minimize number of I/Os.
It's just a fusion
of the two models.
Now, our cache has
blocks of size B.
And you have M over B blocks.
And your disk is also
divided into blocks of size
B. We imagine it being as
large as you need it to be,
probably about order N.
And what can you do?
Well, you can pick up
one of these blocks
and read it in
from disk to cache,
so kicking out whatever
used to be there.
You can do computation
internally,
change whatever these items
are for free, let's say.
You could measure
time, but usually
you just measure a number
of memory transfers.
And then you can take
one of these blocks
and write it back out
to disk, kicking out
whatever used to be there.
So it's the obvious
hybrid of these models.
But this turns out to
be a really good model.
Those other two models,
they were interesting.
They were toys.
They were simple.
This is basically as simple,
but it spawned this whole field.
And it's why we're here today.
So this is a really
cool model, let's say,
tons of results in this model.
It's interesting to see--
I'm going to talk about
a lot of models today.
We're sort of in the middle
of them at the moment.
But only two have really
caught on in a big way
and have led to lots
and lots of papers.
This is one of them.
So let me tell you some basic
results and how to do them.
A simple approach algorithmic
technique in external memory
is to scan.
So here's my data.
If I just want to read items in
order and stop at some point N,
then that cost me order N
over B memory transfers.
That's optimal.
I've got to read the data in.
I can accumulate, add them
up, multiply them together,
whatever.
One thing to be careful
with those is plus 1,
or you could put
a ceiling on that.
If N is a lot less and B, then
this is not a good strategy.
But as long as N is
at least order B,
that's really efficient.
More generally, instead
of just one scan,
you can run up to M
over B parallel scans.
Because for a scan,
you really just need
to know what is my
block currently.
And we can fit M over
B blocks in our cache.
And so we can advance
this scan a little bit,
advance this scan a little
bit, advanced this one,
and go back and forth.
In any kind of interleaving we
want of those M over B scans,
some of them could
be read scans.
Some of them could
be write scans.
Some of them can go backwards.
Some of them could go forwards,
a lot of options here.
And in particular,
you can do something
like given a little
bit less than M
over be lists of
total size N, you
can merge them all together.
If they're sorted lists,
you can merge them
into one sorted list in
optimal N over B time.
So that's good.
We'll use that in a moment.
Here
I have a little bit of
a thought experiment,
originally by Lars Arge
who will be speaking later.
You know, is this
really a big deal?
Factor B doesn't sound so big.
Do I care?
For example, suppose
I'm going to traverse
a linked list in memory, but
it's actually stored on disk.
Is it really important
that I sort that list
and do a scan versus jumping
around random access?
And this is back
of the envelope,
just computing what
things ought to be.
If you have about a gigabyte
of data, a block size of 32
kilobytes, which is probably on
the small side, a 1 millisecond
disk access time,
which is really fast,
usually at least 2
milliseconds, then
if you do things
in random order,
on average every access is going
to require a memory transfer.
That'll take about
70 hours, three days.
But if you do a scan, if
you presorted everything
and you do a scan, then it
will only take you 32 seconds.
So it's just 8,000 in time
space is a lot bigger than we
conceptualize.
And it makes things that were
impractical to do, say, daily,
very practical.
So that's why we're here.
Let's do another problem.
How about search?
Suppose I have the
items in sorted order,
and I want to do binary search.
Well, the right thing
is not binary search,
but B-way search, so log
base B of N. The plus 1
is to handle the
case when B equals 1.
Then you want log base 2.
So we have our items.
We want to search, first,
why is this the right bound?
Why is this optimal?
You can do an information
theoretic argument
in the comparison
model, assuming
you're just comparing items.
Then whenever you
read in a block--
if the blocks have
already been sorted,
you read in some block--
what you learn from
looking at those B items
is where your query guy, x,
fits among those B items.
You already know everything
about the B items,
how they relate to each other.
But you learn where x is.
So that gives you log of B
plus 1 bits of information,
because there are B plus
1 places where x could be.
And you need to figure
out log of N plus 1 bits.
You want to know where x
fits among all the items.
And so you divide log of N
plus 1 by log of B plus 1.
That's log base b
plus 1 of N plus 1.
So that's the lower bound.
And the upper bound is, you
probably have guessed by now,
is a B-tree.
You just have B items
and the node sort
of uniformly distributed
through the sorted list.
And then once you
get those items,
you go to the appropriate
subtree and recurse.
And the height of such a tree
is log base b plus 1 of N,
and so it works.
B-trees have the nice
thing, you can also
do insertions and deletions
in the same amount of time.
Though, that's no
longer so optimal.
For searches, this
is the right answer.
So, next thing you
might want to do--
I keep saying,
assume it's sorted--
I'd really like some
sorted data, please.
So how do I sort my data?
I think the Aggarwal
and Vitter paper
has this fun quote about, today,
one fourth of all computation
is sorting.
Some machines are devoted
entirely to sorting.
It's like the
problem of the day.
Everyone was sorting.
I assume people
still sort, but I'm
guessing it's not the
dominant feature anymore.
And it's a big deal, you know.
Can I sort within one
day, so that all the
stuff that I learned today
or all the transactions that
happened today I
could sort them.
So it turns out the
right answer for sorting
bound is N over B log
base M over B of N over B.
If you haven't seen that, it
looks kind of like a big thing.
But those of us in the know
can recite that in our sleep.
It comes up all over the place.
Lots of problems are
as hard as sorting,
and can be solved in
the sorting bound time.
To go back to the
problem I was talking
about with Floyd's model,
the permutation problem,
I know the permutation.
I know where things
are supposed to go.
I just need to move
them there physically.
Then it's slightly better.
You have the sorting
bound, which is essentially
what we had before.
But in some cases, just doing
the naive thing is better.
Sometimes it's better to just
take every item and stick it
where it belongs in
completely random access.
So you could always do it, of
course, in N memory transfers.
And sometimes that is slightly
better than the sorting bound,
because you don't
have the log term.
And so that is the right
answer to Floyd's problem.
He got the upper bound right.
In his case, M over B is 3.
So this is just log base 2.
But he missed this one term.
OK.
So why is the sorting
bound correct?
I won't go through
the permutation bound.
The upper bound's clear.
Information, theoretically,
it's very easy
to see why you can't do
better than the sorting bound.
Let's set up a little
bit of ground rules.
Let's suppose that whatever
you have in cache, you sort it.
Because why not?
I mean, this is only
going to help you.
And everything you
do in cache is free.
So always keep the cache sorted.
And to clean up the
information that's around,
I'm going to first do a
pass where I read a block,
sort the block, stick
it back out, and repeat.
So each block is presorted.
So there's no sorting
information inside a block.
It's all about how blocks
compare to each other here.
So when I read a block--
let's say this is my cache,
and a new block comes in here--
what I learn is where those B
items live among the M items
that I already had.
So it's just like
the analysis before,
except now I'm reading B items
among M instead of one among B.
And so the number of
possible outcomes for that
is M plus b choose B.
So you have M plus B things.
And there's B of them
that we're saying
which of the B in the order
came from the new block.
You take log of that,
and you get basically
B log M over B bits that
you learn from each step.
And the total number of
bits we need to learn
is N log N, as you know.
But we knew a little bit of
bits from this presorting step.
This is to clean this
up at the beginning.
We already knew N log B bits,
because each of those B things
was presorted.
So we have B log B per
block each of them.
There's N over B of them.
So it's N log B.
So we need to learn
N log N minus N log B bits.
And in each step, which is a
log of N over B N log N over B--
and in each step, we
learn B log M over B.
So you divide those
two things, and you
get N over B log
base M over B and N
over B. It's a good exercise
in log rules and information
theory.
But now, you see it's
sort of the obvious bound
once you check how many bits
you're learning in each step.
OK.
How do we achieve this bound?
What's an upper bound?
I'm going to show you
two ways to do it.
The easy one is mergesort.
To me, the conceptually
easiest is mergesort.
They're actually
kind of symmetric.
So you probably know
binary mergesort.
You take your items, split
them in half, recursively sort,
merge.
But we know that we can
merge M over B sorted lists
in linear time as
well in N over M time.
So instead of doing
binary mergesort
where we split in
half, we're going
to split into M over
B equal sized pieces,
recursively sort them
all, and then merge.
And the recurrence we
get from that, there is--
did I get this right?
Yeah.
There's M over B sub-problems,
each of size a factor of M
over B smaller than N.
And then to do the merge,
we pay N over B plus 1.
That won't end up mattering.
To make this not matter,
we need to use a base
case for this recurrence that's
not 1, but B. B will work.
You could also do M, but
it doesn't really help you.
Once we get down to a
single block, of course,
we can sort in constant time.
We read it and sort
it, write it back out.
So you want to solve
this recurrence.
Easy way is to draw
a recursion tree.
At the root, you have
a problem of size N.
We're paying N
over B to solve it.
We have branching factor M
over B. And at the leaves,
we have problems with size B.
Each of them has constant cost.
I'm removing the big Os to
make this diagram both more
legible and more correct.
Because you can't use big Os
when you're using dot dot dot.
So no big Os for you.
So then use sum
these level by level,
and you see we have
conservation of mass.
We have N things here.
We still have N things.
They just got distributed up.
They're all being
divided by B linearity.
You get N over B at every
level, including the leaves.
Leaves you have to
check specially.
But there are indeed
N over B leaves,
because we stop
when we get to B.
So you add this up.
We just need to know how
many levels are there.
One is log base M
over B of N over B.
Because there's N over B leaves
branching factor M over B.
So you multiply, done, easy.
So mergesort is pretty cool.
And this works really
well in practice.
It revolutionized the
world of sorting in 1988.
Here's a different approach, the
inverse, more like quicksort,
the one that you know is
guaranteed to run [INAUDIBLE]
log N usually.
Here, you can't do
binary quicksort.
You do M over B root M
over B-way quicksort.
The square root is necessary
just to do step one.
So step one is I need to split.
Now, I'm not splitting
my list into chunks.
In the answer, in
the sorted answer,
I need to find things that are
evenly spaced in the answer.
That's the hard part.
Then, usually, you find
the median to do this.
But now, we have to find
sort of square root of M
over B median-like elements
spread out through the answer.
But we don't know the answer,
so it's a little tricky.
Then once we have those
partition elements,
we can just do it.
This is the square root of
M over B-way scan again.
You scan through the data.
For each of them, you see how
it compares to the partition
elements.
There aren't very many of them.
And then you write it out
to the corresponding list,
and you get square root
of M over B plus 1 lists.
And so that's efficient,
because it's just
a scan or parallel scans.
And then you recurse, and
there's no combination.
There's no merging to do.
Once you've got
them set up there,
you recursively sort,
and you're done.
So the recurrence is exactly
the same as mergesort.
And the hard part is how do
you do this partitioning?
And I'll just
quickly sketch that.
This is probably the most
complicated algorithm
in these slides.
I'll tell you the algorithm.
Exactly why it works is familiar
to if you know the Bloom
at all, linear time
merging algorithm
for regular internal memory.
Here's what we're going to do.
We're going to read in M items
into our cache, sort them.
So that's a piece of the
answer in some sense.
But how it relates
to the answer,
which subset of the answer
it is, we don't know.
Sample that piece of
the answer like this.
Every root M over B
items, take one guy.
Spit that in an
output of samples.
Do this over and over
for all the items--
read in M, sort,
sample, spit out--
you end up with this many items.
This is basically a trick
to shrink your input.
So now, we can do inefficient
things on this many items,
because there aren't
that many of them.
So what do we do?
We just run the regular linear
time selection algorithm
that you know and love
from algorithms class
to find the right item.
So if you were splitting
into four pieces,
then you'd want the
25%, 50%, and 75%.
You know how to do each
of those in linear time.
And it turns out
if you re-analyze
the regular linear
time selection, indeed,
it runs in N over B
time in external memory.
So that's great.
But now, we're doing this
just repeatedly over and over.
You find the 25%.
You find the 50%.
Each of them, you
spend linear time.
But you multiply it out.
You're only finding root
of M over B of them.
Linear time, it's not N over
B, it's N divided by this mess.
You multiply them
out, it disappears.
You end up in
regular linear time,
N over B. You find a
good set of partitions.
Why this is a good set
is not totally clear.
I won't justify it here.
But it is good, so don't worry.
OK.
One embellishment to the
external memory model
before I go on is to
distinguish not just saying,
oh, well, every block
is equally good.
You want to count how
many blocks you read.
When you read one item,
you get the whole block.
And you better use that block.
But you can
furthermore say, well,
it would be really good if I
read a whole bunch of blocks
in sequence.
There are lots of reasons
for this in particular.
Disks are really good
at sequential access,
because they're spinning.
It's very easy to seek to
the thing right after you.
First of all, it's easy
to read the entire track,
the whole circle of the desk.
And it's easy to
move that thing.
So here's a model
that captures the idea
that sequential block reads or
writes are better than random.
So here's the idea
of sequential.
If you read M items, so you read
M over B blocks in sequence,
then each of those is considered
to be a sequential memory
transfer.
If you break that sequence, then
you're starting a new sequence.
Or it's just random
access if you don't fall
into a big block like this.
So there's a couple of
results in this model.
One is this harder version
of external memory.
So one thing is
what about sorting?
We just covered sorting.
It turns out those are pretty
random access in the algorithms
we saw.
But if you use binary
mergesort, it is sequential.
As you binary merge,
things are good.
And that's,
essentially, the best
you can do, surprisingly,
in this model.
If you want the number of
random memory transfers
to be little o of
the sorting bound--
so you want more than
a constant fraction
to be sequential--
then you need to use
at least this much
total memory transfers.
And so binary mergesort
is optimal in this model,
assuming you want a reasonable
number of sequential axises.
And the main point
of this paper was
to solve suffix-tree
construction
in external memory.
And what they prove is
it reduces to sorting,
essentially, and scans.
And scans are good.
So you get this
exact same trade-off
for suffix-tree construction,
fair representation.
I have to be careful, because so
many authors are in those room.
Cool.
So let's move on to
a different model.
This is a model that
did not catch on.
But it's fun for
historical reasons
to see what it was about.
You can see in here two issues.
One is, what about a
deeper memory hierarchy?
Two levels is nice.
Yeah, in practice, two
levels are all that matter.
But we should really
understand multiple levels.
Surely, there's a
clean way to do that.
And so there are a bunch of
models that try to do this.
And by the end, we get
something that's reasonable.
And HMM is probably one of
my favorite weird models.
It's "particularly simple."
This is a quote from
their own paper,
not that they're boastful.
It is a simple model.
This is true.
And it does model, in some
sense, a larger hierarchy.
But the way it's
phrased initially
doesn't look like this picture,
but they're equivalent.
So it's a RAM model.
So your memory is an array.
If you want to access position
x in the array, you pay f of x.
And in the original
definition, that's just log x.
So what that corresponds to
is the first item is free.
Second item costs 1.
The next two items cost 2.
The next four items cost 3.
The next eight items
cost 4, and so on.
So it's exactly this
kind of memory hierarchy.
And you can move items.
You can copy.
And you can do all the
things you can do in a RAM.
So this is a pretty good
model of hierarchical memory.
It's just a little hard.
So, originally, they
defined it with log x
based on this book, which is
the classic reference of VLSI
at the time by Mead and Conway.
It sort of revolutionized
teaching VLSI.
And it has this
particular construction
of a hierarchical RAM.
I Don't know if RAMs are
actually built this way.
But they have a
sketch of how to do it
that achieves a
logarithmic performance.
The deeper you are, you pay log.
The bigger your
space is, you need
to pay logarithmic to access it.
OK.
So here are the results
that they get in this model.
I'm not going to prove them.
Because, again, they follow
from the results in some sense.
But you've got matrix
multiplication, FFT sorting,
scanning, binary search, a
lot of the usual problems.
You get kind of weird running
times, log, log, and so on.
Here, it's a matter of
slow down versus speed
up, because everything is going
to cost more than constant now.
So you want to
minimize slowdowns.
Sometimes you get constant.
The worst slow down
you can get is log N,
because everything you
can access in, at most,
log N time in this model.
But I would say setting f of
N to be log N doesn't really
reveal what we care about.
But in the same paper, they
give a better perspective
of their own work.
So they say, well, let's
look at the general case.
Maybe log x isn't
the right thing.
Let's look at an
arbitrary f of x.
Well, you could
write an arbitrary f
of x as a weighted sum
of threshold functions.
I want to know is
x bigger than xi.
If so, I pay wi.
Well, that is just
like this picture.
Any function can be
written like that
if it's a discrete function.
But you can also think
of it in this form
if the xi's are sorted.
After you get beyond
x0 items, you pay w0.
After you get beyond x1 items
total, you pay w1, and so on.
So this gives you an
arbitrary memory hierarchy
even with growing
and shrinking sizes,
which you'd never
see in practice.
But this is the general case.
And we are going to
assume here that f
is polynomially bounded to make
these functions reasonable.
So when you double the input,
you only change the output
by a constant factor.
OK.
Fine.
So we have to solve
this weighted sum.
But let's just look
at one of these.
This is kind of the
canonical function.
The rest is just a
weighted sum of them.
And if you assume this
polynomial bounded property,
really it suffices
to look at this.
So this is called
f sub M. We pay 1
to access anything beyond
M. And we pay 0 otherwise.
So they've taken general f
with this deep hierarchy,
and they've reduced to this
model, the red-blue pebble
game, which we've already seen.
I don't know if they
mentioned this explicitly,
but it's the same model again.
And that's good, because
a lot of problems-- well,
they haven't been
solved exactly.
I would say, now, this
paper is the first one
to really say, OK,
sorting, what's the best
way I can sort in this model?
And they get something.
Do I have it here?
Yeah.
They aim for a
uniform optimality.
This means there's
one algorithm that
works optimally for this
threshold function no matter
what M is.
The algorithm
doesn't get to know
M. You might say
the algorithm is
oblivious to M. Sound familiar?
So this is a cool idea.
Of course, it does
not have blocking yet.
But none of this
model has blocking.
But they prove that if
you're uniformly optimal,
if you work in the red-blue
pebble game model for all M
with one algorithm,
then, in fact, you
are optimal for all
f of x, which means,
in particular for the deep
hierarchy, you also work.
And they achieve tight bounds
for a bunch of problems here.
You should recognize
all of these bounds
are now, in some
sense, particular cases
of the external memory bounds.
So like sorting, you have this.
Except there's no B. The B has
disappeared, because there's
no B in this model.
But, otherwise, it is N
over B log base M over B
of N over B and so
on down the line.
They said, oh, search here is
really bad, because caching
doesn't really help for search.
But blocks help for search.
So when there's no B, these
are exactly the bounds
you get for external memory.
So I mean, some of
these were known.
These were already
known by Hong and Kung,
because it's the
same special case.
And then the others followed
from external memory.
But this is kind of neat.
They're doing it in a somewhat
stronger sense, because it's
uniform without knowing
M. So the uniformity
doesn't follow from this.
But they get uniformity.
And therefore, it
works for all f.
OK.
They had another
fun fact, which will
look familiar to
those of you who
know the cache-oblivious
model, which we'll get to.
They have this
observation that while we
have these algorithms that are
explicitly moving things around
in our RAM, it
would be nice if we
didn't have to write that down
explicitly in the algorithm.
Could we just use least
recently used replacement,
so move things forward?
That works great if
you know what M is.
Then you say, OK, if I need to
get something from out if here,
I'll move it over here.
And whatever was least
recently used, I'll kick out.
And at this point,
this is just a couple
of years prior to this paper.
Sleator and Tarjan did the first
paper on competitive analysis.
And they proved that
LRU or even first in,
first out is good in the
sense that if you just
double the size of your cache--
oh, I got this backwards.
TLRU of twice the
cache is, at most,
TOPT of 1 times the cache.
So the 2 should be over here.
Great.
And assuming you have a
polynomially bounded growth
function, then this is only
losing a constant factor.
OK.
But we don't know what M is.
This works for the
threshold function f sub m.
But it doesn't work for
an arbitrary function f,
or it doesn't work uniformly.
And we want a uniform solution.
And they gave one.
I'll just sketch it here.
The idea is you have
this arbitrary hierarchy.
You don't really know.
I'm going to assume
I do know what f is.
So this is not uniform.
It's achieved in
a different way.
But I'm going to basically
rearrange the structure
to be roughly
exponential to say, well,
I'm going to measure
f of x as x increases.
And whenever f of x
doubles, I'll draw a line.
These are not where
the real levels are.
It's just a conceptual thing.
And then I do LRU
on this structure.
So if I want to access
something here, I pull it out.
I stick it in here.
Whatever is least recently
used gets kicked out here.
And whatever is
least recently used
gets kicked out
here, here, here.
And you do a chain of LRUs.
Then you can prove that is
within a constant factor
of optimal, but you do
have to pay a startup cost.
It's similar to move
to front analysis
from Sleator and Tarjan.
OK.
Enough about HMM sort of.
The next model is called BT.
It's the same as HMM,
but they add blocks.
But not the blocks that we know
from computer architecture,
but a different
kind of block thing.
It's kind of similar.
Probably, [INAUDIBLE] constant
factors and not so different.
So you have the old thing
accessing x costs f of x.
But, now, you have
a new operation,
which is I can copy
any interval, which
would look something like
this, from x minus delta to x.
And I can copy it to
y minus delta to y.
And I pay the time to seek
there, f of max of x and y.
Or you could do f
of x plus f of y.
It doesn't matter.
And then you pay plus delta.
So you can move a big
chunk relatively quickly.
You just pay once to get there,
and then you can move it.
This is a lot more
reasonable than HMM.
But it makes things a lot
messier is the short answer.
Because-- here's a block move--
these are the sort
of bounds you get.
They depend now on f.
And you don't get the
same kind of uniformity
as far as I can tell.
You can't just say,
oh, it works for all f.
For each of these problems, this
is basically scanning or matrix
multiplication.
It doesn't matter much until f
of x gets really big, and then
something changes.
You Dot product, you
get log*, log, log, log,
depending on whether your f
of x is log or subpolynomial
or linear.
So I find this kind
of unsatisfying.
So I'm just going to move
on to MH, which is probably
the messiest of the models.
But in some sense, it's the
most realistic of the models.
Here's the picture
which I would draw
if someone asked me to draw
a general memory hierarchy.
I have CPU connects to
this cache for free.
It has blocks of size B0.
And to go to the next memory,
it costs me some time, t0.
And the blocks that I read here
of size B0, I write of size B0.
So the transfers
here are size B0.
And one has potentially
a different block size.
It has a different
cache size, M1.
And you pay.
So these blocks are subdivided
into B0 sized blocks,
which happen here.
This is a generic multi-level
memory hierarchy picture.
It's the obvious extension
of the external memory model
to arbitrarily many levels.
And to make it so
easy to program,
all levels can be
transferring at once.
This is realistic, but
hard to manipulate.
And they thought, oh,
well, l parameters
for an l-level
hierarchy is too many.
So let's reduce it to two
parameters and one function.
So assume that B [? does
?] grow exponentially,
that these things grow
roughly the same way.
with some aspect ratio alpha.
And then the ti--
this is the part
that's hard to guess--
it grows exponentially.
And then there's some f
of i, which we don't know,
maybe it's log i.
And because of that,
this doesn't really
clean the model enough.
You get bounds, which,
it's interesting.
You can say as long as f of
i is, at most, something,
then we get optimal bounds.
But sometimes when f of
i grows, things change.
And it's interesting.
These algorithms
follow approaches
that we will see in a
moment, divide and conquer.
But it's hard to state
what the answers are.
What's B4?
I think that's just a typo.
That should be blank.
I mean, it's hard to
beat an upper bound of 1.
It also seems wrong.
Ignore that row.
All right.
Finally, we go to the
cache-oblivious model by Frigo,
et al. in 1999.
This is another clean model.
And this is another of the two
models that really caught on.
It's motivated by all the
models you've just seen.
And in particular, it picks up
on the other successful model,
the External Memory
Model and says, OK,
let's take External Memory
Model, exactly the same cost
model.
But suppose your algorithm
doesn't know B or M.
And we're going to analyze
it in this model knowing
what B and M is.
But, really, one algorithm
has to work for all B and M.
This is uniformity from the--
I can't even remember
the model names--
not UMH, but the HMM model.
So it's taking that
idea, but applying it
to a model that has blocking.
So for this to be
meaningful, block transfers
have to be automatic.
Because you can't manually
move between here and here.
In HMM, you could manually
move things around,
because your memory is
just a sequential thing.
But now, you don't
know where the cutoff
is between cache and disks.
So you can't manually
manage your memory.
So you have to assume
automatic block replacement.
But we already know
LRU or FIFOs only going
to lose a constant factor.
So that's cool.
I like this model,
because it's clean.
Also, in a certain sense, it's
a little hard to formalize this.
But it works for changing B,
because it works for all B.
And so you can imagine even
if B is not a uniform thing--
like the size of tracks
on a disk are varying,
because circles have
different sizes--
it probably works
well in that setting.
It also works if your cache
gets smaller, because you've
got a competing process.
It'll just adjust, because
the analysis will work.
And the other fun thing
is even though you're
analyzing on a two-level
memory hierarchy,
it works on an arbitrary memory
hierarchy, this MH thing.
This is a clean
way to tackle MH.
You just need a
cache-oblivious solution.
Cool.
Because you can
imagine the levels
to the left of something and
the levels to the right of some
point.
And the cache-oblivious
analysis tells you
that the number of transfers
over this boundary is optimal.
And if that's true
for every boundary,
then the overall
thing will be optimal,
just like for HMM uniformity.
OK.
Quickly some techniques
from cache-oblivious.
I don't have much
time, so I will just
give you a couple sketches.
Scanning is one that generalizes
great from external memory.
Of course, every
cache-oblivious algorithm
is external memory also.
So we should first try all the
external memory techniques.
You can scan.
You can't really do M
over B parallel scans,
because you don't
know what M over B is.
But you can do a constant
number of parallel scans.
So you could at least
merge two lists.
OK.
Searching, so this is the
analog of binary search.
You'd like to achieve log
base B of N query time.
And you can do that.
And this is in Harald
Prokop's master's thesis.
So the idea is pretty cool.
You imagine a binary search
tree built on the items.
We can't do a B-way, because
we don't know what B is.
But then we cut it
at the middle level,
recursively store the
top part, and then
recursively store
all the bottom parts,
and get root N
chunks of size root
N. Do that recursively, you get
some kind of lay out like this.
And it turns out
this works very well.
Because at some level
of the recursion,
whatever B is-- it
doesn't know when
you're doing the recursion.
But B is something.
And if you look at
the level of recursion
where you straddle B here,
these things are size, at most,
B. And the next level up
is size bigger than B.
Then you look at a
root to leaf path here.
It's a matter of how
many of these blue
triangles do you visit.
Well, the height
of a blue triangle
is going to be
around half log B,
because we're dividing in
half until we hit log B.
So we might overshoot by a
factor of 2, but that's all.
And we only have to pay 2
memory transfers to visit these.
Because we don't know how
it's aligned with a block.
but at most, it fits
in 2 blocks, certainly.
It's stored consecutively
by the recursion.
And so you divide.
I mean, the height
of this thing,
it's going to be log
base B of N times 2.
We pay 2 each.
So we get an upper bound of 4.
Not as good as B-trees.
B-trees get 1 times
log base B of N. Here,
we get 4 times log base
B of N. This problem has
been considered.
The right answer is
log of e plus little o.
And that is tight.
You can't do better
than that bound.
So cache-oblivious
loses a constant factor
relative to external
memory for that problem.
You can also make this dynamic.
This is where a
bunch of us started
getting involved in this world,
in cache-oblivious world.
And this is a sketch of one of
the methods, I think this one.
That's the one I usually teach.
You might have guessed these
are from lecture notes,
these handwritten things.
I'll plug that in in a second.
So sorting is trickier.
There is an analog to mergesort.
There is an analog
to distribution sort.
They achieve the sorting bound.
But they do need an assumption,
this tall-cache assumption.
It's a little different
from the last one.
This is a stronger
assumption than before.
It says the cache is taller
than it is wide, roughly,
up to some epsilon exponent.
So this is saying M over B
is at least B to the epsilon.
Most caches have that property,
so it's not that big a deal.
But you can prove
it's necessary.
If you don't have it, you can't
achieve the sorting bound.
You could also prove you cannot
achieve the permutation bound,
because you can't do that min.
You don't know which
is better, same paper.
Finally, I wanted
to plug this class.
It just got released
if you're interested.
It's advanced data structures.
There's video lectures
for free streaming online.
There are three lectures
about cache-oblivious stuff,
mostly on the data
structure side, because it's
a data structures class.
But if you're interested
in data structures,
you should check it out.
That is the end of my
summary of a zillion models.
The ones to keep
in mind, of course,
are external memory
and cache-oblivious.
But the others are kind of fun.
And you really see the
genesis of how this was
the union of these two models.
And this was sort of the
culmination of this effort
to do multilevel in a clean way.
So I learned a lot looking
at all these papers.
Hope you enjoyed it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Are
there any questions?
AUDIENCE: So all these are
order of magnitude bounds
I'm wondering about
the constant factors.
ERIK DEMAINE: Are you
guys going to talk
about that in your final talk?
Or who knows?
Or Lars maybe also?
Some of these papers
even evaluated
that, especially these guys
that had the messy models.
They were getting the
parameters of, at that time,
[INAUDIBLE] 6,000 processor,
which is something I've
actually used, so not so old.
And they got very good
matching even at that point.
I'd say external memory does
very good for modeling disk.
I don't know if people
use it a lot for cache.
No, I'm told.
Cache-oblivious, it's a
little harder to measure.
Because you're not trying
to tune to specific things.
But in practice, it seems to
do very well for many problems.
That's the short answer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it runs faster
than [INAUDIBLE] cache aware.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
It does better than
our analysis said
it should do in some sense,
because it's so flexible.
And the reality is very messy.
In reality, M is
changing, because there's
all sorts of processes
doing useless work.
And cache-oblivious
will adjust to that.
And it's especially the
case in internal memory,
in the cache world.
Things are very messy and fussy.
And the nice thing
about cache-oblivious
is because you're not
specifically tuning,
you have the potential to
not die when you mess up.
AUDIENCE: I'd say
that's especially
the case in the disk world.
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh, interesting.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] But--
ERIK DEMAINE: These
are the guys who know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] people
have different [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
They're both relevant.
AUDIENCE: What's the future?
This is history.
ERIK DEMAINE: OK.
Well, for the future, you should
go to the other talks, I guess.
There's still lots of open
problems in both models.
External memory, I guess,
graph algorithms and geometry
are still the main topics
of ongoing research.
Cache-oblivious is similar.
At this point, I think--
well, also geometry
is a big one.
There's some external
memory results
that have not yet been
cache-oblivified in geometry.
AUDIENCE: Multicore.
ERIK DEMAINE: Multicore.
Oh, yeah, I forgot
to say I'm not
going to talk about
parallel models here.
Partly, because of lack of time.
Also, that's probably
the most active--
it's an interesting active
area of research, something
I'm interested in particular.
There are some results about
parallel cache-oblivious.
And all of these papers
actually had parallelism.
These had parallelism
in a single disk.
There's another model
that has multiple disks.
Those behave more
or less the same.
You basically divide
everything by p.
These models also tried
to introduce parallelism.
Or there's a follow up
to UMH by these guys.
So there is work
on parallel, but I
think multicore or
cache-oblivious is probably
the most exciting unknown
or still in progress stuff.
AUDIENCE: Thank
the speaker again.
ERIK DEMAINE: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]